reality winner leaked a secret report on
Russian election hacking to the media
and will now serve more than five years
in prison that's the longest sentence
ever imposed for this kind of violation
the former NSA contractor and airforce
linguist has been held in a Georgia jail
since last June and is currently
awaiting transfer to a federal prison
after her sentencing last week the
document winner leaked to the intercept
was the first time the public learned
that the Russian government tried to
infiltrate state election systems in
2016
she is the first person to be sentenced
under the Espionage Act since the Trump
administration took office only on CBS
this morning reality is calling us now
from the Lincoln County Jail in Georgia
for her first television interview her
her plea agreement she cannot answer
questions about any classified material
or her motivation for leaking the
document and joining us at the table is
her mother Billie winner Davis good
morning and thank you so much for
joining us
reality thank you for joining us on the
phone as you were there in jail let me
ask you this because it was the document
that you leaked that really brought
everyone's attention to this idea about
the Russians trying to infiltrate and
attack our state voting systems which at
the time was not common knowledge what
has it been like to see the Russia
investigation unfold from behind bars
vindicating but also frustrating I know
that had I been out and allowed some
kind of opinion about it I would be
doing my due diligence as a citizen
contacting my senators but as it is I've
just been behind bars kind of a
spectator and kind of a bounding box to
other people's opinions when I call
people they're so frustrated or you know
the mail I get people are just venting
to me about the state of the country you
leaked these documents to the intercept
and the editor in chief Betsy Reid has
said this about you instead of being
recognized as a conscious driven
whistleblower who's just
closure helped protect us elections
winner was prosecuted with vicious
resolve why do you think the government
is making an example out of you
well it was mid 2017 and I was the first
one
however Friday you know even our
commander-in-chief President Trump has
kind of come out and said wait a minute
this is really unfair there's this
double standard here and for that I
can't thank him enough because there's
16 months those words so unfair were
actually not allowed by either myself or
my team or my family to really stay out
in the public so I just can't thank him
enough for finally saying what everybody
has been thinking for 16 months that's
right the president United States Donald
Trump tweeted this X NSA contractor to
spend 63 months in jail over classified
information gee this is small potatoes
compared to what Hillary Clinton did so
unfair Jeff double-standard I think he's
referring to Jeff Sessions the Attorney
General
do you believe you now have the support
of President Trump I don't like to
assume anything as to what's going on in
his head but the small potatoes was a
breath of fresh air it really made me
laugh it reminded me of you know me and
my own family and we try to make a joke
out of everything we laugh every single
day no matter how bad things get and he
really gave us a whole sense of humor to
the thing because it is quite bizarre
reality you said you feel vindicated by
what's happened in the Russia
investigation but you've also said this
was a mistake was this mistake worth it
you know what I've learned in my time
here is that you can disagree with
someone too you're blue in the face you
can talk all you want but what really
matters is how you treat the person next
to you you know kindness is an art that
can be practiced anytime and anywhere
and what you do in your community no
matter how small it is if you help just
one person that day you change the whole
world so
I just wish that that's where my mindset
had been two years ago
well prosecutors said that the community
you were a part of was the national
security community and that what you did
wasn't just within your own world but
that it threatens sources and methods do
you agree with that framing you know I
really can't comment on that reality on
Twitter you reportedly called the
president once an orange fascist you've
been very critical of him what do you
think of him now and are you hoping for
a presidential pardon you know I'm not
going to sit around and wait for
blessings and I just like I said I don't
like to assume what goes on in his head
but back to what I said before is that
you know back then I was all about what
I disagreed with and what I've learned
now is that disagreeing doesn't get you
anywhere
and that no matter if I walk out of this
place tomorrow or in 48 months at the
end of my sentence no matter who's
president my life is gonna be dedicated
to community service and you know after
I read the tweet and thought you know
that wild hope of a presidential pardon
I thought no I need to pray I need to go
back to God and I need to just think
about the next step and when I can hug
my mom again because you know 30 minutes
through glass on phone sometimes don't
even work I mean that's not enough I
just need my family in my arms again
whether it's on visitation in prison or
in Hell by some grace of God that I get
out of here sooner but I don't like to
ask for anything or assume that anything
is going to happen you know reality just
didn't remind people who you are how
many languages do you speak right now
but yes I've been educated in three
other languages besides English
languages and you were involved in a lot
of different intelligence matters I know
after you were arrested you said you
didn't think about the consequences of
what you did now that you know the
consequences do you regret leaking those
documents
yeah deeply and well what would you tell
anybody else who is in a similar
position to the one you were in go
volunteer in your community
[Music]
you know or just walk down the street
shaking hands with everyone that you
know I think that I was isolated at that
time and psychologically you're not
gonna make the best decisions and just
realize that there are other people out
there for you and that what matters is
just what we do every single day like
you can change the world before
breakfast just by being kind of somebody
reality you've been in jail now for more
than a year what is your day-to-day like
and do you feel like you can change
someone's life where you are changing
anyone's life before breakfast there I
really do try try to make sure the
ladies are up for breakfast because it's
the best start to any day but we do try
to help we several of the girls you know
before they leave or go on to wherever
they're going I give them my mom's phone
number and they check in with us and you
know I've got my little sister KK I know
she's been on Twitter a few times
talking about me and my other sister
Sarah got out a couple weeks ago she and
she's doing really well and we just try
to keep tabs on everybody like I don't I
don't let people just you know disappear
out of my life like smoke I really do
hold on to each and every person that
I've met here reality I just wanted to
remind our viewers about what you did
because according to prosecutors you
printed out this classified report on
May 9th that was the day that President
Trump fired James Comey the director of
the FBI were you aware of commis firing
did that influence why you been sent
this document to the intercept you know
I don't really remember anything from
that month so I really can't comment on
any of that reality you you signed up
you served in the Air Force and you
dedicated part of your life to your to
your country and yet the prosecutors in
the case quoted you is saying you hate
America where do you stand on your
country
you know I love my country more than
ever and when they tried to take away
you know just verbally take away my
military service I think that that took
a part of me away that I haven't really
seen in you know 16 months and it broke
my heart more than anything else my
service to the Air Force was everything
I've ever wanted and it was amazing it
was the best six years of my life but I
I do I love my country I'm a patriot I
care about this country and I want to
make it as good as it can get but taking
little words or statements out of
context you know they were able to you
know try to damage my character and it
took everything I had not to kind of
believe their narrative because when
you're sitting there in that orange
uniform and they're the ones saying you
know telling you who you are it's so
really you start to believe them and you
know as if I didn't have the support of
my family or people around the world
thing we see through this you know I
would have been lost reality you'll be
about 30 years old a little older when
you do get released from jail what do
you plan to do with the rest of your
life well I am going to start getting a
bachelor's in social on sociology and
Social Welfare and hopefully move back
down to South Texas and you know I'm a
Texas by heart and detected by heart
pardon me it's very early and I'm
nervous
and kind of go into Social Work the way
my mom did my whole life I know that we
have a refugees situation on our border
and just if I can't change the system or
the legislation then I want to make sure
that I can start non-profit programs for
these children and parents and young
adults to make sure that every day that
they spend counts and that they get to
work towards their American dream even
if it's unsure that you know it'll come
to fruition or not so that
you know their lives are enriched in
Tazewell can you describe and I know
you're talking about the future and and
changing your profession why did you
join the military in the first place and
how did you end up at the National
Security Agency I wanted to be a
linguist I I wanted to know I wanted to
know certain languages and work in that
field to have an understanding you have
one minute left oh that's nice racket
system at the prison that tells us how
much time is left in the phone
conversation go ahead reality so I
wanted to serve I not wanted to be
working right away you know I didn't
want to talk about it I don't want to go
to college for five years I just wanted
to be about it and they gave me a such a
profound perspective of the world that
is absolutely priceless I think
everybody should serve that we you know
at least four years
yeah it's just it's hard to explain in
30 seconds all right well reality winner
I know this has been your first
television interview and joining us from
inside jail we thank you so much for
spending your time with us I know now
that they cut off the time so thank you
again and hope to talk to you soon
secure it goodbye joining us now is
reality's mother Billie I know you get
to speak with your daughter every day
but let me just ask you to hear what she
has been accused of espionage treason
against her own country that's been
difficult that has been that's been
something that from the beginning I I
was fighting and I didn't want for her
to be convicted or to plead guilty of
espionage
you know espionage implies that you're a
traitor that you're a spy and that is
absolutely not
anything that she did well I think about
reality winner because I'm not sure
everybody remembers who she is although
the president tweeted about her on
Friday yes he did yes he did that was to
me if he does nothing more he at least
validated us because yes I believe that
her treatment has been unfair from the
beginning the way that they have handled
her case from the beginning the charges
that they brought against her from the
beginning the way that they you know
characterized her as a villain and you
don't believe she's a villain you
believe she's a patriot because she was
the first to really raise awareness
about what the russian intelligence unit
was trying to do in terms of influencing
our election system I do I do believe
that I believe that the information that
she leaked should have been released I
don't understand why our intelligence
community didn't release it to us I
don't understand why they didn't warn
the states that were at risk but when
you have a job like hers you agree not
to leak this kind of thing so while the
treatment and the sentence may be harsh
and that's what the president was
talking about he and others would say
the system can't work if individual
members of it who've promised
not to leave this kind of information
just on their own decision decide to go
ahead and hand it out I understand and I
agree with that yes I agree that there
are rules there are procedures there are
laws and did reality violate that yes
she did but is she guilty of espionage
she's not guilty of espionage she
pleaded guilty to it she did that was
her only choice though yes if she's not
guilty of espionage what then is she
guilty of if she's if you say she made a
mistake there's other charges that they
could have looked at such as mishandling
of classified information if that would
have been a little that would have been
more appropriate for her do you think
the size of her sentencing is meant to
send a message to anybody else who would
do this I know it is because the
prosecution said it in their sentencing
memo they said it there in the courtroom
last Thursday and the judge also then
repeated it that nobody thinks that
reality winner is at risk of doing
anything again but they needed to send a
message they needed her sentence to be a
deterrent all right really winner Davis
thank you so much for joining us we
appreciate it thank you